Speaker 1: And Democrats came out after, of
course, all the spotlights been on Joe Manchin
this week and said, we're going to play hardball
with him next year. Yup. Joe Biden, President Joe
Biden says he is not done with his talks with
Joe Manchin, this isn't over. They're going
to continue on with this, Chuck Schumer says.
We're going to play hardball with Joe Manchin.
We're going to make this thing happen. And
they're going to start putting pressure on him.
And that's what's been needed this whole time, I
want everybody to think for a second in terms of
in the Senate, who were the people you have seen
publicly come out and call out Joe Manchin, who
are sitting in the Senate today. Well, not today.
They're on vacation. But you know what? I mean,
who? Chuck Schumer has. Bernie Sanders
has. Pretty sure Elizabeth Warren has.
There's three. Three out of three out of 50 that
I know of. Now, that's not to say they're the only
three. Sure, plenty of other folks could have
flown under the radar. Maybe their statements,
their comments didn't quite get the attention
that the comments of these other folks had.
But why? And Bernie Sanders made headlines
for a day and a half last week by saying
Joe Manchin and Kirsten Cinema were acting
like Republicans. But part of the pressure
campaign that has to be put on Joe Manchin, the
hardball the Democrats say they're going to play.
Means that it can't just be Bernie saying they
can't just send Bernie out to be the attack dog
and then later on and be like, Well, he's not
really a Democrat, so that's why he can do it.
No, Bernie Sanders is more of a Democrat than Joe
Manchin could ever hope to be in his life, trust
me. In fact, he's more of a Democrat than any
of the Democrats in that Senate, but either way.
You can't just have one guy, you can't have
three people. Elizabeth Warren is tough.
She is absolutely. Just. An attack person and a
passionate person, and I love Elizabeth Warren.
But that's also not enough. There has to
be this united front. And that's what the
Democratic Party has been lacking. You know, sure,
you're not going to get cinema to join in on the
attacks on Joe Manchin to to really pressure him.
You're not going to get tester to do it either.
But you can get a handful, you know, 10 to 15
other Democratic senators to band together and go
public with this, and that's what you have to do.
It can't just be one guy doing an interview here
or Elizabeth Warren doing an interview over here
and, you know, making passing comments about Joe
Manchin and both of them. And then the interviewer
moves on to something else that's not good enough.
It has to be press conferences. It has to
be meetings. And then after the meetings,
you have to do another press conference
and talk about how he wouldn't
go along with what you needed and how much that's
going to harm the people of the United States.
Those are the points you hit on. You don't
just talk about, Oh, everybody's going to
suffer by this. No say, listen, because
of this man obstructing this legislation,
you don't get that child tax credit
money in your bank every month anymore.
Because of his decision here, we're not going
to have child care expenses paid for for you.
We're not going to have lower costs for
prescription drugs, we're not going to have
the $35 insulin, that's a part of the legislation.
We're not going to transition to renewable energy.
We're going to keep burning the dirty fossil
fuels. That's the message you go forward with,
but you have to go forward with it with as
united of a front as you can put together.
It can't be a piecemeal patchwork of one senator
over here on MSNBC saying at one on CNN saying it
and then nobody talks about it for another month.
No. And you can't put it all on Joe Biden, either.
It can't just be Manchin and Biden talking
again, no. It has to be everybody, everywhere,
every time, all the time going after him and
playing hardball. So again, the Democrats say
they're going to play hardball with Joe Manchin
in 2022 and I am here for it all day long.
But you have to do it right. You can't just
come across as a bunch of bullies who are mad
at mansion. Put the real pressure on him. Remind
the public of what's at stake and eventually, if
you're united and strong, you might just be able
to crack him. I'm Farron Cousins. You can find
me on YouTube at YouTube dot com slash fair and
balanced youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire and
Ring of Fire podcast at RAAF podcast dot com. I'll
be right back with more on the David Pakman show